hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the zoo race nose
Adventure 2 now if you know about this
game it's part cuz you watched John
Tron's video about it
John Franz lovely he a story about this
awesome incredible game and when I
finished watching I had to go check out
see if it was an actual game that
everyone could play this is it totally
is it exists and his takes itself kind
of seriously on the website unless it's
all part of it ins inside jokes so if
you don't know about it I apologize
here's the deal you are the animals
surviving after Noah got you on his ark
and there was the flood and then there's
a big celebratory race and that's it
okay so I'm gonna pick my character I
wanted to be the bear um and that's
about it I'm gonna just I'm gonna kind
of go for it because I already saw the
video about it and this is really me
doing oh god why is there green farts
coming out of the ground
ohh oh boy ha ha can't wait
yeah ok
Oh God how do I go wait how do I go wait
oh oh I got to use the arrow keys not
the mouse okay I got a cookie wait but
how much I control the camera with the
mouse Oh Oh God where am I going how
hello person oh oh oh my goodness oh my
goodness I'm legitimately oh okay I'm
just gonna carry on now Oh No
oh oh oh I think I remember the level
from what is what are what what are
those nickels
those aren't humble he's that for sure
oh hi uh-huh okay Oh at least this is a
multinational did I win i won oh god why
this is the victory screen if you win
whoo all right
congratulations Bethany the pair oh no
it's really striding to get to the
winner's circle I feel so good about
myself I'm not gonna have nightmares
later no way not me oh is that my dance
pose at my pretty little dance look at
my little hat on me I'm so happy that I
won Bethany the bear really did a number
on that and then she went in the woods
and stole picnic baskets and ripped
people to shreds as I hiked in the woods
oh here we go again oh I think it's
criminal to have a game be this much fun
well everything seems normal so far oh
no never mind I forgot I forgot okay you
go tiger blasting off oh we're in water
now okay and there's a a bomber hello up
there I am legitimately losing my mind
here
I'm slipping off into another world
where I'm a tiger and everyone's racing
and what the hell is in front of me even
what what are you you look like a bald
baboon get out of here okay wasn't that
much of a problem it just made me kind
of kind of a little bit shaky Oh
thank you farmers what time period are
we in oh man I don't even like to use
the phrase I can't even but I can't I
can do I can't can't handle I can't
handle then hear this it's not okay this
game it's too good this game looks too
good
okay no I did it tomorrow okay what up
I can still jump ah one one off I go
just you jump off this cliff first okay
I'm still I'm still going I'm okay
good bye everybody else oh my people
need me I'm off to another world I'm the
king I'm the champion and oh that I I
went out of the world everyone else
turned black oh no what did I do
wouldn't they do to Noah okay I think
I'm in the lead now oh I'm going to the
moon I'm going to the moon
I'm going to the moon oh man I can't
believe this game is not only real but
serious oh oh oh it's so beautiful
Oh Sophia I'm on the moon time on the
pepper
I can't I'm dying it's so good this game
is sooo good I'm gonna die I can't do it
I have to record so much more today but
this game is gonna end
why are there birds haunting you know
what oh no doesn't know with Noah
anything is possible
Noah oh no God the goat no you
how could you God the Mayan goat
Oh oh well I don't know about you guys
but that's about as much as I could
possibly handle of the zoo race oh oh
there's so many songs and they're all
dancing oh this is beautiful so anyway
if you want a great game that's
wholesome for the whole family play the
zoo race knows adventure - it's great
there's a link down in the description
below
enjoy everybody and thank you all so
much for joining me and if you want to
see John John's video on it's funnier
than this one I bet so check it out in
the description below thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye buddy
blooming Bonnie whatever Bonnie are you
okay buddy are you all right Bonnie just
talk to me Bonnie
I have to slow